[Music]
most people's will to win is for sale
they can be Bob
the people who only prioritize money
never make money concentration will
power practice yes all those are
important those are the ingredients but
how much do you want it rise and shine
it's an espresso time what's that belief
nation it's Evan I believe in you and
this channel is designed to be part of
your daily success routine so let's
start your day off right to get there
grab your coffee and sip on today's
message don't sell your will to win over
you ed my life most people's will to win
is for sale is for sale most people's
will will is for sale win is for sale
they can be Bob I can't be Bob so if we
give you just most people if we gave me
just enough money if there's a certain
dollar amount it's not working all right
I owe you stop working hard we give you
a car or a plane or a house or actually
if the book bro is above at the book
yeah that might be the book that is the
book so what your will to win is for
sale that's right and I decided once I
realize that because I want happen with
people in their body and their finances
and their family and their faith
whatever it is I want I'm not for sale
so there isn't a place you're gonna buy
me you can't get me there's not a stop a
place of destination where you're gonna
get me to collect to quit I want to
improve that doesn't mean I don't
struggle with my motivation from time to
time doesn't mean I don't get confused
or down of course idea but I'm not for
sale yeah you can't buy me and you know
this too we see a friends of ours even
guys in their 60s and they sold their
company for blah blah blah now they golf
nine days a week or whatever you know
that's fun but yeah for sale
they burbot you were bought you were for
sale this is why it's so important to
have a mission when you have a mission
you're not for sale when you know what
you're doing when you have a deep
purpose and you are off chasing it you
are not for sale
money is really important but if you
look at the success of people look at
anybody who look up to who you respect
who's your hero who's your here who's
your greatest most famous entrepreneur
of all time that you love and you would
love to emulate money was not the most
important thing to them there was
something
of money now money is important money is
important for every business money is
important for every organization if
you're a charity money's still important
but it's not number one and you got to
figure out what you would put ahead of
your money so many people are just
chasing money money money money and I
get it it's important I had I had a
woman who was at my seminar last night
here in Indianapolis who she has eight
different side hustles and now she's
trying to get into real estate to try to
make money and the problem is none of
its purpose driven and none of it is
actually making her enough money she's
making just enough just little tiny bits
from these side hustles that she can
barely survive it's a wrong path the
people who only prioritize money never
make money they never make the real
money you make just enough to survive
cuz your will to win is for sale you've
got to figure out what your purpose is
you got to figure out who you are you
got to figure out what the mission is
that you're on when you do that then no
matter how much money is being thrown at
you you're not gonna accept it because
you're on a deep purpose for life I love
helping entrepreneurs you can't throw
money at me to say stop doing it this
fills me up for life
so great find your purpose Wow amazing
how do you do that what are the steps
what's the process I'm gonna give you a
three step process that will help you do
this
if you're lost you trying to figure out
how to make money you trying to figure
out where to go next in your life this
is the Baths figure this out you are set
for life it's called the higher purpose
planner gonna figure your who your why
and your have higher purpose finder step
low on your who what's your one word
what's your most important core value
what are you staying for every human
being has a single most important core
value figure that out you're set for
life
so mine is believe I stand on my rock
believe you can't shake me from it I'm
not swayed by your opinions or your
values the problem is people don't know
what they stand for and so you're being
pulled in all these different directions
well he wants me to do that she wants me
to do this this person wants to do that
you're pulled all over the place you're
constantly judging yourself you worry
about the opinions of other people so
much because you don't know what you
staying for so you have to figure out
and your one word most important core
value is you might know it just coming
off the top your head if not I have a
great book you can go through and it'll
help you step number two is your why
your purpose
comes from your pain your purpose comes
from your pain think about the most
painful moment in your life of all time
what was it what did you struggle with
what's the most painful moment in your
life your purpose is now to help other
people who are currently going through
that pain that's your purpose for life
it will fill you up for life so I love
believing in people why entrepreneurs
because I struggle so much as an
entrepreneur because making it $300 a
month because I was too embarrassed and
ashamed to tell my friends that I wasn't
making any money because I had to eat
the same bean salad for lunch every day
because it was cheap and it filled me up
because when I got a new client in my
business we went to McDonald's and we
celebrated with a large french fries
between the three of us because it
couldn't afford a meal like I get it I
love entrepreneurs that I love the
startups more than anything because
that's the pain I love helping
entrepreneur go from 1 million to 10 I
love helping them figure that out but
deep down it's the startup I don't want
people to have to suffer as much as I
suffered I don't people have to struggle
as much as I struggled that's my why and
so you think about the most painful
moment in your life thinking about the
time that you never want to have to
repeat the time that you would never
wish upon anybody in your family or even
your worst enemy to have to go through
that struggle that thing that we want to
bury in the past is actually the key to
the future for you and it's sometimes
hard to access because we're optimistic
as entrepreneurs we're looking forward
to a brighter future we don't want to
live in a pain in the negativity it
doesn't mean you live there but you use
it as a fuel source to help get you to
where you want to be and have a huge
impact your purpose will be helping
those people who are currently facing
the struggle the pain the suffering that
you went through if you can help take
somebody and lift them out of that pain
it'll fill you up to a degree I can't
even explain that's your purpose last
point is the house so the who the why
the how the how is figuring out how
you're gonna actually go off and do it
there's a lot of ways that I could be
believing in entrepreneurs tons of ways
not all them I'd love to do not the
process that most successful people in
the world enjoy the process you have to
enjoy the action not just the result if
you're just chasing the result you're
never gonna be happy you're never gonna
be ultimately successful you have to
enjoy the process of
thing there's a lot of ways that could
be believing in entrepreneurs if you're
trying to set up a new website I could
come over and help you and figure out
how to put a website together pretty
quickly I don't like doing that though I
don't want to do that I like making
videos I like doing presentations I like
doing seminars I like cretan course it's
like I this is the work that I love
doing I love it I love it so make a list
of ten twenty thirty all the ones you
can think of the ways that you have
helped people and you enjoy helping
people humans have built to serve you
will always love helping people you have
to even if you're introverted and you
don't want to be around people all the
time you will still get filled up by
helping others you are meant to serve
and help other people if you're not
happy you're not serving enough great
making a list of all the ways that you
have served that helped other people and
then circle the ones that you enjoyed
the process of not just the result of
helping them then you're set
you're set for life you know you're who
you know what your one word most
important core value is you know your
why your purpose comes from your pain
you're gonna want to serve those people
for life and then three you know your
how you know the process you know the
process that you love that you fell in
love with that if you did every single
day it would fill you up and bring you
so much joy that's how you do it that's
how you make sure your wills not for
sale most people's wolves for sale
because they don't know what they're
about they're not mission driven they
don't know what the purpose is you want
to be everybody wants to everybody knows
that there's something greater for you
you know there's a purpose for you most
people just don't know what it is
because we don't teach this stuff we
don't train this stuff now I want to
change it so figure out your higher
purpose follow those three steps change
your life now I've got a really special
bonus clip that I think you're gonna
enjoy but before that question the day I
want to know what is your purpose put it
down the comments below tell me I want
to see it I want to read it leave it in
the comments another quick story so I
didn't have money for a car and my x19
with the hole in the floorboard had died
and so I literally the way I got my car
was I saw a car that was stranded on the
side of the road this old Camaro and I
forget exactly how but I figured out
which bank had had put the money up for
it for somebody to buy and I called the
bank and I said would you let me pick up
the payments on this you know only I
need you
lower the payments down a little bit and
they said yes so I had this you know
nineteen eighty-something
um Trans Am that I was able to use but
the point being that you just have to do
things you never think you're gonna have
to do in order to survive and get
through it you know those first couple
months I remember thinking to myself I'm
in business in two months now you know I
remember getting to the point where I
had $15,000 in sales probably six months
into the company and I'm still living in
the [ __ ] and thinking okay I can do
this I can do this and along the way it
was lots of trial and error you know
there were things that were new to me
things that were terrifying to me things
that would just I would break out into a
sweat but I always remember going into
my customers and just trying to be
brutally honest and say to them if I can
help you right if I can bring value if I
can make your company more competitive
more profitable will you work with me
and you don't have to put money I'll do
the work to prove it and if I get it
done then we'll meet you know we'll
figure it all out you know or they agree
to a price and then they'll paid at that
point and one by one I just kept on
making customers happy and lost some you
know for every one I lost picked up
three and I got I was so nervous about
the whole thing that you know I just I
couldn't imagine slowing down you know
and so people talk about you know life
family balance I had none I mean I
literally remember dating some girl this
is truth and it was like we'd been
dating a couple years like it mark
you're so into your work I mean I want
to picket fence I want a house I want
kids you know I mean you it's me or your
job and I was like or me and your me or
your company and I was like what's your
name again
[Music]
I'm like if you don't know me well
enough by now two years know that I'll
contribute on this I mean there was no
balance a good friend of mine is a new
kid who want a gold medal in netball
control events are acknowledged for
beach volleyball and so I interviewed
her in Australia a couple of months ago
when we're talking about it and I said
what drove you to win yeah and most
people don't want it enough you know and
if people ask me you know it's like how
do you go to monster how do you leave
your family behind your friends
everything ice cream chocolate yeah
Beach you know go anything that you can
imagine and go there the monster for 10
years and no contact because you want it
it just comes down to how much you
really want my concentration willpower
practice yes all those so important
those are the ingredients but how much
do you want it if you really really want
it you will make it work but most people
don't want it enough yeah my teacher
used to say to me all the time
if you want something new you have to
give up something old yeah was sitting
on the couch and if you want to bring a
brand new couching it would have to get
rid of this put on top of this coat and
the sacrifice is such a good thing you
have to give up the always do a
different thing parts of your life in
order to gain something you like you
have to want it you really really have
to want it and that's why they go from
one self-help book to another cell phone
book to another self-help book and they
say well you're not picking the best
pots out of here
it's like a buffet you know you just
pick what you want and you never commit
to anything fine one thing commit to it
and if you want more edmy let check at
the top 10 rules video that I made on
him the link is right there next to me I
think you'll enjoy it continue to
believe and I'll see you there
the comfortable road will never lead you
to the person you were destined to be
ever in your life